stewey coming down to rebound puts one
the birth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's WNBA stars and four-time Olympic
gold medalist each year four times Sue
Bird and Diana Taurasi scoring against
China the US women's basketball team
will compete this summer in Tokyo and
could make history by becoming the first
women's team in any Olympic team sport
to win seven straight gold medals like
sound of that
this comes after players including
burden Taurasi negotiated new WNBA
contract this month that could enable
some top players to more than triple
those triple their salaries sue Burton
and Diana Taurasi will join us have
joined us now to talk about that it all
started with a crayon we'll get to that
in a second but first let's talk about
Kobe for a second because I know you all
have been rocked as we all have and you
both knew him very well he called you
Dianna the white Mambo what does that
mean for you I mean you know it's just
been such a difficult time for a lot of
people or that new Kobe I think we
talked about earlier I didn't know Kobe
there was a connection with his work
ethic and how serious he took his craft
and the mom of mentality means what I
mean like what in a white we know at all
cost
yeah I mean I think he said at one time
it's to overwork your potential and I
think that's what he did more than
anything is he obviously had god-given
skills but he was gonna work I'll ask
him and overwork your pretension you
know when I heard that and when I saw
him play I was a freshman high school
when he was a rookie with the Lakers
being from Los Angeles so you know just
growing up with him yeah your life every
single day there was a connection that
goes beyond bathroom you know him - yeah
so I knew and we met him you know
multiple times I got to spend time with
him at the Olympics but I actually got
to I'm from New York yeah that was more
a Knick fan yes but Dee and I go way
back and I actually got to experience
Kobe through Diana's eyes which was
which was really interesting we played
overseas together remember every every
Laker game she'd come in you see what
Kobe did yeah score she was a big fan so
even though I wasn't a fan of him
growing up per se he wasn't my favorite
player I got to see the impact directly
how did he support the women's game I
mean you see it he was at the games he
present he spoke about it obviously his
relationship with his daughter who was
in a
firing WNBA player you come player
actually yeah well you're both you come
you both exactly that was a wonderful
tribute they gave to her her name as
hard as it ever GG yeah as hard of a
time as it's been it was really nice to
be with each other with USA basketball
to be on that UConn court a place like
you said GG wanted to play and be able
to honor him in that way and honor her
as well so let's talk about the Olympics
you mentioned playing overseas together
I mean many of the in the women's game
go overseas to supplement their income
but now as you train for the Olympics
there's a plan to pay each player a
hundred thousand to train right here in
the u.s. why does that matter we spent
most of our careers in Russia we spent
ten years there playing and I think we
talked about it earlier with the the new
CBA what we're doing with the national
team
we want to keep people here that's the
plan how did you come up with a hundred
thousand and not fifty or not 250 and
how did it start how did it start with a
crayon are you all just sitting in a
restaurant and you start spitting out
ideas what happened yeah exactly
you know when you play overseas there's
a lot of downtime yeah you're pretty
you're bored not a lot of people are
awake that used to talk about your box
of crayons you literally just chat and
we were actually in America on a USO
that's that's the one little one little
part we're showing you so yeah we were
just like we're talking or spin ideas
doing this and we're like who has a pen
who has a pen we need to write this down
and we were our agent who has a
two-year-old son at the time and she was
like all I have is this purple crayon
you're like perfect but how did you come
up with $100,000 guys as opposed to any
figure I think that figure you know
whenever you talk about amount of money
ya have to go through different
resources and different avenues and I
think working with USA Basketball
working with other players that was the
number that we felt really comfortable
with that people would want to stay and
actually do it so that's how that came
how was it received when you put it out
there really well I mean this is two
years in the making right like a great
thing it's gonna take some time to build
we we had a group chat which was like
pretty much all the Olympians from 2016
and we were like what do you think of
this and just kind of laid it out and
everyone was like oh I'd be in that
times change injuries happen yeah at the
same time the WNBA's rolled out a new
contract a significant increase how does
that change things I mean it just it
puts us in a different category
I think the tone of what the WBA was for
the last 10 years I think just took this
negative connotation of why would I want
to play there where I think with the CBA
and the things that we've fought for now
it's something that you can strive and
as a little kid you want to play the WBA
now for different reasons what was it
just last year the year before the
league MVP had hurt herself playing
overseas in the offseason again because
it was a financial thing she's making
more money will this new contract mean
that you don't have to travel in the
offseason you could be with your
families you can be at home yeah that's
the hope the hope is to listen we're
starting in a way from scratch right
we've lived this young MBA life for 20
plus years but now this is like a whole
new life and we're figuring it out but
the idea is like Dee said like you're
saying so people don't have to go
overseas there's opportunity here and
hopefully it just continues to grow and
let's talk about sue for a second your
other half notice I didn't say better
half who's also involved in an equal
paid dispute with the soccer league how
is her fight different from yours and
how frustrating is in 2020 women are
having this conversation about equal pay
so how different is your fight for your
yeah it actually is different you know
Meghan's fight and her teammates that's
with us soccer which is a federation
it's a nonprofit so there's some
different you know situation with you
know us wmba
yeah and we understand that we're
business a lot of people think we're
sitting here saying oh you should pay
it's the same as the NBA no we
understand that's not what we're talking
about but where they're similar is you
know equity and being marketed the same
and being treated the same and those
types of things so it's great to have
somebody obviously that I can talk to
you bounce ideas I've learned so much
yeah I've learned so much yeah I think
it's a two-way street as Dee and I were
saying she's the lucky one she's a lucky
one no better half only equal